we're being taken deep into the
ukrainian forest on the western borders
of the donbass
and the soldiers of the 93rd brigade are
waiting for their orders to strike enemy
positions this is their most potent
weapon
she's a 60 year old veteran capable of
firing multiple rockets at once but only
up to 20 kilometers away not enough in
this war
the younger american version can fire a
barrage that reaches hundreds of
kilometers but this is all these
soldiers have right now and they need
her
their orders come in suddenly there's
action
they know they have to move fast
a russian position has been spotted on
the islam front
they're trying to hold back the russian
troops from advancing south
and attacking the donbass from yet
another front
they take dusty forest roads to avoid
detection from drones
if they're spotted they will definitely
be targeted
the crew line up their barrage of
rockets and adjust the targets
these grads are not precision weapons
they can fire a full load of 40 122
millimeter rockets over a wide area in
under 20 seconds
they recheck their coordinates
this time they've decided to split the
attack into two salvos so he instructs
them to launch the second twenty
this is what the russians have a lot of
and which the ukrainians want to see
more of and they say will make all the
difference in the war
we've got to move quickly now
they have to get out of the area because
they know the russians will be looking
to fire on this position and obliterate
the crew
this is what they're up against
the ukrainian government says this shows
the russians using thermobaric bombs on
the donbass
this is what the most horrific war of
the 21st century looks like the
statement said
the ukrainian troops on the front line
are horrifyingly exposed having to
defend large stretches of open land and
keep an enemy at bay who they are rarely
close enough to see
the russians are using their long-range
artillery to constant devastating effect
the smoke that you can see there shows
the russian positions as a village which
is half controlled by the ukrainians and
half by the russians
chief is asking his troops what the
situation's like there they've been
shelled an hour or so earlier
this small band of men have been holding
this position for weeks now
coming under constant attack every few
hours from russian positions
oh here we go end law they proudly show
us some of the foreign weapons which
have helped so far where's this one from
it's from britain
they're designed to destroy tanks at
short range with a single shot and they
need little training to operate
but here in the forest and farmland its
capability is limited ivan tells us
in this position it isn't that effective
he says because their tanks don't come
closer than three and a half kilometers
and this weapon can't reach the target
at that distance effectively
they need long-range artillery and tanks
themselves he says if they're to stop
this reinvigorated russian invasion
yeah you can see them in the distance
they've had some crucial successes
though recently somehow managing to stop
several russian tanks from crossing the
dam just in front of them and planting a
ukrainian flag to emphasize this
territory is still very much theirs for
now
but they've been some tough sacrifices
they're only just recovering from their
latest attack they lost four of their
comrades here
there's just a single helmet on the spot
where they fell a constant reminder of
what they've lost and how slim the
division is between surviving here and
not
then distant sounds of incoming fire
the shelling started again now he says
okay there's lots of incoming now
hurry she tells us
the ukrainians are finding it hard to
stop the russian troops here as they use
their scorched earth tactics to snatch
territory in the donbas
they're busily moving tanks and other
hardware to the shifting front lines in
the east but the numbers are not in
their favor
alex crawford sky news eastern ukraine